[Musique]
mon deuxième domicile
je suis tombé directement de la
maternité de port royal en 27 ville
salle du parc montsouris
je devais avoir dans les huit jours et
une maison bien ordinaire bien
bien bête bien laine soie comme toutes
les autres du quartier ya pas encore de
plats que je suis pas blasé que ça
vienne quand tout ça c'est la frontière
déjà ça parce qu'après c'est le
cinquième oui on change de quartier
genova longtemps à franchir cette
frontière là d'ailleurs j'ai mis 25 ans
je retourne donc à tort on est méfiant
il ya des liens on n'aime pas tellement
passé des fondeurs
la rive droite tu en parles pense à
cette dame schéma nice et si l'affairé
chaussée le quartier des bonnes soeurs
mais à l'époque où j'étais gosse la nuit
ici les y aller il ya aucune bonne femme
seule qui voulait remonter cette année
là on se faisait à plus ou un violet ou
assassinés c'était vraiment un bel air
il ya toujours pas de réverbères
d'ailleurs changé ici non un voyage sur
les petites chapelles plus impitoyable
il ya des congés en il ya des jardins de
jr hectares le mien et au bout il ya
lion de belfort qui est un des
chefs-d'oeuvre du quartier on a tombé
dessus lebel en criant vous voyez là
s'appelle le lion de belfort
je crois qu'il est assez symptomatique
de l'esprit du paysan d'une 14e il est
très laid comme vous pouvez voir et ça
ça fait partie de notre ma liste pour
éloigner le touriste je les ai connus
verdâtre couleur bronze
maintenant on l'a pas en marron c'est
encore plus sachez qu'avant on a
plusieurs petits trésors comme ça
on déduire les vénitiens sont malins par
exemple c'est pas vrai c'est des cons
parce qu'ils ont ils ont fait la plus
belle ville du monde ils ont un million
et demi de touristes par an ils sont
plus jésus vous avez pas vivre ces gens
là c'est pareil à rome c'est un y à
tolède c'est pareil partout dans le 14e
on est chez nous personne nous emmerde
[Musique]
on va là nous voilà devant saint pierre
de montrouge qui est tout de même une
chose imposante
ja je connais la concurrence que le
sacré coeur
mais les touristes sont rués sur le
sacré coeur et là encore on a un coup de
pot inimaginable car personne ne vient
visiter d'intrigués qui pour moi elle
est liée à pas mal de souvenirs
d'enfance
parce qu'elle est voisine de l'école
la rue du moulin vert oui j'ai passé le
certificat d'études avec mention bien et
ça j'y tiens parce que dans mes
relations je connais le gars que j'ai eu
la mention bien aux certif c'est maurice
biraud et francis blanche boulevard qui
ne s'est passé pas mal mais ça les
garçons - là ça n'a pas bougé il ya les
plus gros marché du monde s'en fout là à
dire qu'il ne l'était sous les sous les
acacias s'émerveille yalla yalla spa
hiver cette émission comme ça qui a
l'air de rien et quand j'étais enfin
j'étais en gt plus bas j'étais
adolescent c'est là j'ai rencontré ces
argiles cometti enfin des gens qui ont
fait leurs cheveux tout ça c'est le
passé
ah oui la rue du cimetière lé lé calme
et là on y faisait des promenades
sentimentale bar ici parce qu évident
que le soir c'est pas déjà les chevrons
ne pas dire que ça circule beaucoup mais
la nuit c'est plus que le calme
on pouvait y faire des petites haltes
comme ça tranquille la droite c'est une
des artères les plus importantes du
quartier la rue de la gaîté alors là
j'ai entoilage 2
de 12 ans et de 18 ans j'ai bien aimé
latin peu tous les soirs la brayelle
bobino qui était un centre d'attraction
et puis à côté de bobino il ya un petit
musée qui s'appelle le moulin de la y
était et puis maintenant c'est new york
dans la rue là on n'est plus chez nous
on sait entre au fus c'est une autre vie
c'est un autre monde
c'est pas mal d'ailleurs mais moi je
n'ai pas encore eu le temps ni vers la
halle by halle digne alpes affiche plus
rien elle parc montsouris c'est un seul
endroit paisible du quartier à ça à
l'air paisible comme ça ait l'air la
nouvelle génération mais moi j'ai des
souvenirs plus revenant du point la nuit
une fois les grilles du parc fermé hier
là on enjamber les grilles et puis on
passe et prend pas la nuit bien sûr mes
enfants en travers les 1h du matin on
restait dans la halle parc était à nous
c'était nadia à partir de là temps en
temps il y avait des cours est avec les
gardiens quand même c'est arrivé au
stage là en cavale et 1
viens là on va approcher dollars une des
pièces artistiques les plus étonnantes
du 14e arrondissement
l'observatoire du wagon sourit ça je
crois que ça mérite le détour quand même
pas je vous l'avais promis nous y voilà
alors ça c'est à la fois notre place
saint-marc nos chutes du niagara nos
pyramide c'est la pièce artistique
métrage du 14e arrondissement
c'était paraît-il
ça a été le fruit les amours je veux pas
du bet tunis avec je fais pas trop ça
devait être une shampouineuse de
l'époque et ça a été léguée à la ville
de paris
je crois que maintenant ça sert à
mesurer de la vitesse du vent ça sert
pas mesuré la camry saison juan
[Musique]